本慕课的内容基于这本很棒的书
The content of this MOOC is based on the
fantastic book
注：目前最新版本是第二版
Gramham Hutton 写的 Programming in Haskell
by Graham Hutton: Programming in Haskell.
我十分推荐
I strongly recommend that,
当你听课时
as you follow the lectures, you
阅读书中的对应章节以获取更多的背景知识
read the chapters in the book for extra
background information
和更深的理解 剑桥大学出版社很友善
and deeper knowledge. Cambridge
University Press has been so kind
注：该优惠码已停用，请移步 edX 查看最新优惠码
提供 25% 的折扣
to offer you a 25% discount on
the book,
购买纸质版或电子版
both on the printed version and on the
electronic version.
当然你不需要手动输入这个 URL
Of course, you don't have to type
in this URL here;
课程网站（edX）上可以找到
the URL will be available on the
course website,
请考虑购买这本书
Please consider to get the book
because I think it will
因为我认为它可以大大提升这门慕课的体验
very much enhance the learning
experience of this MOOC.
玩得开心， hacking 愉快！
Have a lot of fun and happy hacking!